where'd you get that jacket I bought it
you bought it yeah the money I gave you
yeah at
Heaven it's cold out
there night it's get warmer now yeah
it's warmer now than it was when I saw
you last
week yeah I know that the sun's out the
rain was so dreary
yesterday I gu said parallels you know
what I mean but then you fly in and the
sun's box
I come back from London and it's
beautiful it becomes
beautiful your hair looks so good I just
I just love it but you look exhausted
have you been okay I just flew back from
London so I'm a little little hammered
from the flight but your hair looks so
fun you should just grow it out don't
wear
[Music]
wigs I love wigs but this is my my hair
your hair looks better than the
wigs thank you male man or woman either
way your hair is
great male or female that make no
difference world
stop okay Carry On so London yeah London
was fun London was fun it was quick just
a
day one day you used to live in London
briefly briefly yeah how old were you
I was in my teens I think I was
like 15 16 I like London it's a nice
city I love
London what's happened since I saw you
you look a little disheveled yeah I
guess I was kind of uh had a bit of a
rough
moment got a little roughed up I guess
it was raining yesterday and
I I slept honestly it was wistful I
don't know you what I slept oh you slept
yesterday through the
rain like
uh kind of felt very
uh don't want to say disheartening but
you know it's like
disengaging what what's your biggest
concern right
now
perception perception of what perception
of the Void
Define I worry I'm very misinterpreted I
guess I don't
know well we're all
misunderstood you're not unique in
that for that I suppose I'm actually
grateful in a sense for a
change I like your friend Jimmy who you
came by my studio with in Santa Monica
uh last week Jimmy crickets yeah he's
great I love Jimmy he was a good
influence on you you showed up clean
shaven and well dressed and showered and
yes somewhat clean somewhat sober
somewhat I think it left your own
devices that you tend to uh go off the
rails
train Rock Amy Schumer you're a little
bit of a train
Rock but everybody still loves you
regardless and I love them except for
the haters and they hate every
everything and everybody but that's just
that's just social media you got to
ignore it I don't get as much hate as I
thought I would honestly no you get lots
of I mean the the reason I post your I
post your videos every Sunday afternoon
on my my channel and I normally post all
the other videos early in the morning so
you're like the one thing that stands
out and and no one can complain that I
post your videos too much because it's
all in addition to what I normally do
which is posting every day all
throughout the year so if you don't like
Rebecca videos just don't [__] watch
them and if you do which most a lot of
my audience does especially the female
part of my audience they love you I
think then there it is in the
afternoon
I think I think I'm one of the I'm one
of the few men that thinks Rebecca's
fascinating I would say 99% of your
audience is
female for that I'm truly grateful
honestly I got all the girls I got all
the girls you love women I love women
every time you come by my studio and
there's a girl a woman there you are
just like so warm and friendly and I PL
I'm FR towards you anyway what's that
are you implying that I'm more frig to
zoo in anyway no no no no no no no
you're nice to me too but but with when
when a when you meet a new female that
comes by the studio you're like oh my
God I love you you're so beautiful
you're so so
complimentary it's like you want to be
one of the pack you want to be one of
the
girls I just want to be one and
everybody excepts you every female that
you've done this to thinks you're the
greatest they all love you I love
them
I think you're amazing I still think
you're amazing with all your ups and
downs and all the
rounds we're getting there yeah I see
potential I see much room for
improvement but definitely potential
last week and even today you're fairly
cogent but last last week when I saw you
I was just like oh my God there's hope
Noel who works with me goes she was all
excited about this is the new Rebecca
I'm like no I don't know I think that
was that was Jimmy's
influence honestly stay tuned watch this
space I'll say that watch this space
okay potential arrives in Spades and
droves are you motivated when people
tell you you're not going to you're
going to [__] up or you're not going to
make it you're not going to be
successful or you're not going to
everything drives me honestly everything
drives me to
pursue um more of a sense of like you
said maybe
cence
cohesion
I think things are really going to start
going the way they're supposed to go
rather than the way they uh maybe
weren't supposed to go let's say
that I find that uh whenever someone
told me I can't do something or if a
girl breaks my heart or whatever that is
all the all the motivation I need turns
into rocket fuel makes helps me do
whatever I need to
do so maybe that's what you might
need a little bit of a push
MH the word need is so much stronger
than the word necessity but necessity is
so much more overarching right
you think the word necessity necessity
is such a grander word but the word need
feels so much more urgent urgent yeah
more
desperate desperation Necessities are
like what soap toothpaste food water um
oxygen perhaps I think oxygen maybe is
the necessity allegedly need seems to
bring in the heart the heart like that
matters of the
heart was not supposed L where we are at
now matters of the
heart still love you guys by the way
thank you to everyone out there for if
even one iota of love that is so much
more appreciated than you will ever know
and I love you so much more for
it I love this
Rebecca this Rebecca and the last
Rebecca in when you first showed up with
your blonde hair those are my those are
just you're so fascinating you're so
interesting you're you're made to be a
star you are made to be a
star watch the space watch this
space let me help you a little
bit I love to see you I would love to
see you just take this ball and run with
it and and just do whatever you want to
do in
life that's let's go here we go no talk
is cheap talk is
cheap you know Money
Talks there's a million people having
coffee on Abid Kenny right now talking
about what they're going to
do and not doing
it that's very true I'm not doing
it maybe it's time to start doing what
needs to be
done
so when you sleep where where do you
sleep anywhere just find a quiet safe
spot Mark i' like to help me I'd love
to maybe one day direct do you feel like
you could motivate me towards that in
some way I can help you sure I don't
know if I can give you motivation but I
can give you the the maybe some
knowledge tools skills whatever you
need that would certainly really help
because lately I've been more edging
towards directing than I thought I would
in
life I thought I was I was going to
serve you know what I mean but lately
I've been more drawn
to you know what they call passion
projects exactly but quite a few I feel
like uh are in the pipeline somewhere
and
uh there's not much that you could tell
me that you want to do that I wouldn't
believe may maybe I doubt you'll be a
hockey player but but or basketball
player but
um but in terms of directing
acting
fashion heck even
music even music yeah you could probably
do anything you could you could do
anything that you're interested
in all those things definitely yeah more
than interesting I'd say with your sense
of style and your creativity just cut it
out you he could do
anything you're
right you're so right thank
you I love you so
much I love you so
much we got a mutual admiration Society
going everybody thinks we're a romantic
couple everyone everyone seems to think
for some reason that there's a
flirtation between us yeah everybody
thinks me and Lauren are a romantic
couple everyone thinks you and I are a
romantic couple courtship dating yeah I
I let everybody wonder what this hell is
going
[Music]
on leave an edge of mystery you know
what I
mean honestly I see so much potential
and it's like it's just frustrating to
watch you [__] it all
up I
agree there's always potential though
there's always I have to keep reminding
myself of your age because you you with
your
knowledge I get the impression that
you're
35 or even older you know you're so
knowledgeable very PL if you to say
honestly in some ways you're very mature
but you're
26 yeah 26 is Young is it young it's
young I don't know sometimes I Don't
Feel So Young you know what I mean
sometimes I feel like it's
all like uh you know they say you're
ship is sale you know what I mean I
worry about that but then sometimes I
feel almost
uh like in the face of I don't I don't
want to say just the universe but in
terms of anything that was like in terms
of matter or material you know what I
mean I feel so almost virgin young I
feel like The Virgin Spring of Youth
like when you think of water for
instance when you look at a particle of
water and think think of just how
Transcendent of time and space that has
been and then you look at just one of
your
like dead ingrown hairs or one of your
little bumps and you're like
w fluidity I think is very important now
to point and shoot is important too but
fluidity what is fluid and what is Neo
fluid you know like almost I think neon
fluidity would make more sense not non
fluidity neon
fluidity to flow back and
forth but also you know like uh shooting
particles are shooting laser beams
shooting laser beams of water can you
imagine if water was given that
strictness you know what I
mean strictness of a laser beam particle
or a Las be particles given the fluidity
of
water imagine total inconsonant pleasure
just
being an actual thing an actual uh
attainable concept like real
pleasure you
know instead of
[Music]
a pain being kind of like the excuse not
to evolve pleasure can become the uh
instinct to
exist in a sort of uh valy simulator
Metropolis everyone could get what they
wanted if they wanted
to is it cooperation or is it more
dissonance that's the
key I'll leave that to you the viewer to
decide I
suppose when you were young what
qualities did you have that stood out
when you were a
boy
shyness insecurity no but not not the
negative ones the positive
ones I'd say I was quite adorable like
lovable in a way you know what I mean
like always wanting
to not just
uh make people happy but always wanting
to make make of the
situation something more you know what I
mean like wanting more out of life maybe
I
suppose yeah but like like when I was a
young boy I was fascinated with
dinosaurs and I knew every dinosaur I
knew the name I knew it was like I was a
college professor and then I dropped
dinosaurs and went on to birds and I
knew every bird that probably existed in
the world and I I knew where they were
from I knew all I knew everything about
everything and it I become very
obsessive and I've always been that way
so that's my strong suit but do you have
anything like that I as a boy cuz you're
so
knowledgeable I don't know what to say
honestly about my Boyhood other than
uh I had to be maybe
uh like tful I guess I don't
know I was very unaware though of
the amount
of beauty and positivity that could
exist in life being more disenfranchised
that I dreamed up
like alternate scenarios where there
were even greater forms of it you know
what I mean so I had this imagination
that that superseded imagination I'd say
like it's like other emotions or other
ways of being that were
more because I felt like I hadn't had
that in my life you know what I
mean so I was able
to isolate create and now attempt to
instigate I don't use the word EMB
betterment I want to use the word again
it's like pleasure you
know I want say it was more of a people
pleaser maybe although I hope that I
please people
today please forgive me for I have
bed are you a religious Man Mark not at
all not at all well I mean I I tell
people that I'm not because I don't want
to talk about religion when people start
talking about religion I just don't use
their video Johnny this Asian gang
member who's had this tremendously
popular video someone who pull the gun
on you no no no no there's a different
guy um okay Johnny is an Asian gang
member that interviewed and he started
talking about religion I was I was
almost not going to use this video but I
said you know what it was a Good's he's
it was a good talk so I used it against
my
normal you know normally I wouldn't use
it because it's so religious and his
video ended up doing really well got
like millions of views and everyone
loved it and I I but I but I am I do
believe in what like
Jesus I part of religion was controversy
I maybe live by that but I don't I don't
I don't
sell
it I'm not a joiner so I won't go to
church sex
SS
trly are you
religious I like the
uh it's like there's the there's a
there's kind of a a duality between the
discipline and the controversy the Adam
and the Eve I don't know everything's
got that exactly but with religion it's
it's more uh placed you know what I mean
like more uh like people seem more
afraid of
the Wrath and torture of God than they
do the instigate of the devil and yet
when it comes to the devil people never
fear any sort of retaliation from him
but they fear the devil more than they
fear God when it comes to uh pain I
suppose or
suffering who is exploiting who
wonder if the devil's being exploited in
some way avoiding pain is more of a
motivator than than pleasure exactly
whereas pleasure should be the
motivation it's not that pain shouldn't
exist I just um if that's your thing
um good luck to you I suppose but that's
not really um what life should be about
should it and life seems to be not just
about the uh dodging of pain but the
uh the just the
uh lost my train of thought there are
you were raised Muslim partly yeah
strictly maybe is it true I heard on my
trip to London I I I interviewed and I
spoke with somebody else who uh they're
both Pakistani M and they were telling
me that divor the the like in the US you
get a man and woman get a
divorce the woman gets half the assets
and the kids usually go to the mother in
pakist I think it was Pakistan or in
Muslim certain Muslim countries the
children go to the man
because the the money does not get split
the woman just she gets whatever kind of
subtle let's say in some very dogmatic
Muslim
societies uh not just our men seen as
the everything is seen as a property
unless you're a man you know what I mean
I think men are the only commodity that
can't be bought and sold apparently in
some of these communities or at least
just handed over you know but but the
woman doesn't get the woman doesn't get
no there isn't there's an equality but
she doesn't have to take care of the
kids the man does no she's expected to
she's expected to that's not true yeah
she has expected stories but it could be
different countries too you're in Egypt
and they were in Pakistan well Pakistan
in Pakistan it's more of a like I said
it's less cultural and
more
socialistic in a sense as in the trading
of religion is more uh social than it is
cultural while in Egypt I suppose
religion is more cultural than it is
social religion is more of a cultural
asset than a social
asset yeah Saudi Arabia is fascinating I
think it's very interesting what's going
on there I mean just middle beast on its
own you know is quite a quite an
achievement just Dubai alone is
fascinating I think Dubai is a standard
of uh let's say stoicism it's a great
way to just kind of uh ease into things
it's okay you know what I me like all
all the Russian polish girls all all the
beautiful women from Europe that moved
to Dubai to uh to
model model is a good word for it model
to model no honestly cuz in life a lot
of what we do is modeling you Model
Behavior you model you pose the question
of activity you know what I mean
all I wanted was a pair of chaa heels
wasn't it
allegedly but no really in all
seriousness
um it's a good thing that it's like
right at the end of that like right at
the end of sex in City to you know what
I mean the fact that just that one level
of that one Outburst
right it's like that's all that anything
would need in order for everything to be
Beyond okay it's just like at the end of
the day it happened
happened doesn't mean uh things won't
get better but you
know one last seed of Menace before the
uh but wait are you optimistic about
your
future in general not like right now but
I mean just definitely no sense I'm more
of a pessimist honestly in terms of um
because you have these self-destructive
traits so it's like
exactly but that means anything can be
destroyed even the barrier itself even
the negative itself can be
destroyed and that alone gives me hope
that maybe one day I
too will have the
uh rights of a human or the lefts of a
could could you handle that human rights
think I could could you handle success I
definitely CER well people say that
sometimes and then when they get it they
don't know what to do with it then you
screw it up yeah
definitely if I were to succeed like
truly start succeeding in life I feel
like I would be more measured about it
so I'd know what to do with it you know
I'd enjoy
it i' exploit it to the point of wanting
others to enjoy it around me and I think
that's why it wouldn't be such a hustle
you know what I mean I wouldn't want to
keep it all for myself
essentially let's all party let's all
enjoy it
let's all take pride in what we've done
you know what I
mean Beyond a grateful I'd be uh well
grateful to everyone honestly who would
have helped along the way but I feel
like they were more the ones who are
worthy of it than I was
honestly and that would further an
exchange of growth
and I keep want to use the word
love cuz is love such a dirty word Love
Is My Religion love is
understanding I Believe In The Power of
Love I do
too and for that I love
you can I get you a nice room
somewhere not on skid row let's start
there
maybe maybe we can start
I just love it if uh people would get to
see the
uh the more attuned me the more not just
refined you know but the more uh
sociable me I feel like I've honestly
been fighting or like pushing against
Society or against people for quite a
while your audience here on my channel
would love to see
that that's what majority of the
comments are like hoping hopeful that
you'll come around to
that I think we're right on the brink of
but you but you have a whole slew of
commenters that say just drop this loser
he's lost he's he's gone and I don't I
don't buy that for a
second I don't think it's too late at
all I do believe A change is going to
come for the better not for the worse I
I just I just
don't put much like when people tell me
what they're going to do it's usually a
list of things they're not going to
do but with you I see so much
intelligence so much creativity so much
talent that I almost think you're you're
you're an exception to the a lot of
rules you're an exception to almost
every
rule when people say oh put Rebecca in a
rehab there's no way you would go to I
don't think you would go to a rehab if
you decided to quit drugs you would just
quit but you're you know that's a
decision that you may make one day but
it's not going to be because you have
had to go to a rehab for six months or
something feel it's more I just need to
adjust my behavior more my attitude more
my appearance for
instance I don't need rehab again I will
say this do you honestly think that if
you got the sex change and became yes I
do a woman that could you imagine if I
genuinely look like a woman right now
like if if that even is still a
possibility at this point which I hope
it is you know what I
mean could you even picture that no you
couldn't for some reason well I mean I
you know so you have
this the the reason I'm hung up on you
being a a man is because you're such a
handsome man which is very sweet of you
to say but you are incredibly handsome
but but I understand you want to be a
woman I'm not I'm not discounting that I
truly do I mean thank you I I see that
okay and and you're not high right now
or you're not super high right now and
you're telling me this so I believe you
sometimes you're telling me this when
you're high as a kite and I'm like [__]
I'm not going to buy any this [__]
but right now and last time you were
here or the other Studio you you were
like
really does it feel more of a CO you're
you're Co in a clear head and you were
telling me this is what you want well
it's true that it is what I want I'm
telling you the only limitations are
what you know to be the the mild sort of
I don't say legal but it's just like a
bunch of paperwork at this point
literally if it were possible for me to
stap my fingers and become a moment then
I would do it in a second in a heartbeat
I mean do you need to have the yes I do
the mail Parts removed a lot of the
trans Community does not want that I I
want that I genuinely want that I genely
don't know what to do with my boy parts
you know what I mean it's like you
remember that song Venus as a Boy by
bork if I could be a woman then I could
Venus and I could truly appear as I
should it's my cosmology or my physical
appearance that seems to so infuriate or
so like irritate people you know what I
mean my my my my beard it's always my
beard or uh or uh my BGE you know what I
mean yeah you you don't seem to be
making an attempt to be a woman so
nobody no one's really buying you as a
woman it's it's the appearance honestly
but it's like I my dad never taught me
how to shave so I don't know how to
shave I don't even have access to like
you
know a razor half the time let alone a
mirror let alone a roof let alone the
running water you know what I mean due
to the nature of my life which you know
we're trying to work
on I'm not even a thir class citizen at
this point so you know I don't
know if on the negative list at this
point it's almost like I'm uh like
giving away more energy than I'm
harnessing at this
point I've thought about this a lot
since I've known you especially when you
keep selling me on this wanting to be
woman wanting to be a woman thing I'm
not selling religion Mark I'm not
selling religion no no no I know but but
it's like but I say woman is my Rel no
but I'm very open-minded so I'm I'm
sometimes I'll think about your
situation and think
maybe if Rebecca had the sex change then
a lot of the problems that we're seeing
the drug problem the the living on the
street and being you know Street urch
and all that stuff might would
definitely go away right I feel like it
would just make me so much more uh not
just appe appealing in society but truly
um I feel like woman has the advantage
at this point or one deserves the
advantage so I find it honestly very um
comforting that it's me as a man that is
uh losing the game of life because it's
supposed me and a as a woman or at least
a woman out there would be allowed to
win and to give women that Advantage
truly is is a gift on its own I'd
say truly a gift I'm coming around
that's good
here thank
you you seem to be a little uh combative
towards that I'm happy that you aren't
so much
anymore all I want is to be a woman
truly well your your your actual hair
when you showed up with the with the
dyed hair now I now I could maybe see
like if you pluck the eyebrows and and
you exactly shaved and and yeah properly
you know maybe maybe some hormones you
might be to yeah that's cuz I don't I
don't really care what sex you are I
just want you to be happy and
healthy I'd be happy as a
woman and
healthy if you can sell me on it you can
probably sell anybody cuz I'm like I'm
not I'm not down as they say with uh
yeah you're not as more conservative
about it yeah I'm not pro ter at all
yeah which is really shocking to me
considering you're so uh when it comes
to things but I guess it's a big part of
California is the Republican uh
close-minded attitude I think if
remember a k I'm aidid I'm from Chicago
I'm just a Midwestern kid yeah but in
Chicago trans women are I know but not
when I was a kid I don't I never saw
them but until I came to La yeah because
honestly outside of La there isn't um
exposure I'd say San Francisco San
Francisco yeah but even San Francisco is
still very um it's more a so like the
society there it's more like a village
you know what I mean whereas La is an
industry I think the the first time I
saw a wow that that is a dude trying to
be a chick was in San Francisco many
years ago first time I ever I don't
enough would have been New York for me
yeah maybe New
York yeah I don't have anything against
San Francisco it's just uh San Francisco
surprises me a little it's not as uh
much of a metropolis as it could be you
know what I mean I feel like it could be
like it has so much potential you know
what I mean like just col and lights
could exist there but for some reason
it's a little like there's this like I
was saying stoicism like kind of
Something's holding it back you know La
is much more open and free it's meant to
be it's meant to be what what I love
about Los Angeles like people from New
York will criticize Los Angeles people
from Chicago will criticize La people
from San Francisco love to criticize LA
and La loves all three of those cities
exactly La loves the pretention that
comes with the association with both NE
YK and Chicago when it comes to San
Francisco I'd say it's the
uh it's more of a they they think it's
Freer there it's more Bohemian I'd say
whereas people hate on La those two
cities hate on because I think everyone
here is living in fabulous wealthy
luxury when I think it's more of a what
is it a cure for wellness you know what
I mean well I think a lot of hate you
you you can see this in in Technicolor
in the comments on YouTube or on any
social media platform hate is just Envy
it's just Envy who yeah honestly who
would envy this you know when people
leave a comment about Rebecca saying oh
this the [__] loser would just dump
them and leave them
alone or or what's a better example
there's a million examples but like when
when somebody's criticizing an
attractive female on my channel uh and
they'll say the cruelest meanest things
it's so clear to me that you're just you
you just wish you look like she did or
or if they're critizing honestly you
wish honestly cuz women to me are like I
don't want to say goddesses but the way
a woman looks is beyond beyond
uncompromisingly alien like there are
very few women I think that are not that
are not beautiful as opposed to men
whereas men can get staunchy and fat and
just regressive in a
way women as they grow older want to
look more beautiful they don't even when
they let themselves go it's kind of out
of a need or a want to be more beautiful
or to be more appealing you know what I
mean whereas men go out of their way as
they grow older to kind of lose their
appeal you don't see as many men want
like staying muscular or staying um
attractive whereas with women they'll go
out of their way to get surgeries they
go out of their way to stay skinny
they'll go out of their way to State
well I'd say more of them than men I'd
say that more than men for sure more
than men for sure men will let it
go men will let it
go but when you think of divorce
honestly I feel like there are more
women out there today who want to
divorce men than there are men who want
to divorce women which is a good thing
divorcing the man because he got out of
shape and let let his body fall apart
whereas men sometimes will do that
exactly but that's something only a man
would
do doesn't mean a woman hasn't done that
in the past either the Sexes are so
different the
Sexes are very
different but I think women deserve uh
I'd say uh a shot at love like I don't
know what to say uh women deserve to win
finally you know what I mean I think we
live at a at a moment in time and space
where we can say that women can finally
have a seat at the table and that um
according to dogmatic
uh the dogmatic retellings of History
hasn't happened in
ages I mean for the first time there are
societies where women can have
sex you understand we were talking about
the Middle East earlier Pakistan or
whatever I don't say or whatever but you
know uh casual sex which you I suppose
would take granted or for granted isn't
so forgiving in the uh what is
referenced to as the third world or in
conservative uh in true conservative
Society even conservatives uh in this
country I suppose would be shocked if
they found out that
sex uh was not as much of
a a permitted uh Behavior permitted
activity in foreign people especially in
the United States do not think of that
or consider that you know what I mean
when we say sex cells you know what I
mean just the appearance of breasts is
bned in several Muslim countries but
they're there aren't they they're there
right your eyes may be up here but they
are there and I think it's the denial of
them and the uh that leads to the
perversion you know what I mean that
leads to the very perverse and negative
view of it you know what I mean like if
a woman's body were to be appreciated it
would grow not just in Beauty but in
In Bloom almost you know what I mean if
you want something to uh be beautiful
you don't make it ugly do
you but sometimes you need ugliness to
contrast Beauty you need something
really ugly to just show up kind of like
Medusa you know what I mean to just show
up to contrast the beauty of guess that
would have that's what would have made
Medusa demig goddess you know what I
mean is it's not just the head of snakes
but it's this this idea of repulsion
this contrast between repulsion
and uh Absolution whereas it's like
power versus repulsion you know Medusa's
uh one uh veered quality in society was
power the one thing they wanted from her
was power the one thing they hated was
her ugliness or how she would use or
abuse UGL in order to get it you
know I don't personally find her ugly in
any way but I love that aspect of the
Medusa the idea of putting
on like the ugliest face or being able
to take like
a
monster and find that one little nugget
of uh of
gold the Gold Rush remember the Gold
Rush Mark what happened to all the gold
who's going to use all the gold now that
it's been excavated I wonder is it just
going to sit there in Fort Knox Riv or
we just going to blow it up I don't
know is anyone actually going to I mean
other than jewelry what else could we
use all that gold for could you imagine
like gold statues everywhere gold
buildings or gold IM drinking golden
water could you imagine what drinking
golden water would do not piss I think
there is a drink that has gold flakes in
it or something not gold flakes I'm
talking about Liquid Gold Liquid Gold oh
because Liquid Gold heat right heat is
the factor so what if we weren't so
allergic to heat what is it a fear of is
it the fear of burning or is that the
fear of pain which do you think is the
motivator with drinking molten uh me no
no no with going to H I'd
say is it the pain or is it the
burn are they the same thing no they
aren't do they have to be does a fire
have to hurt you no it doesn't what if
it can be manipulated and not to hurt
you would you walk through it of course
you
would through the fire I would walk for
you my love through the fire I would
walk for
you with tears of stride not a child
bride but a dead
hide of selfless
flesh let's start there maybe I don't
know wouldn't that be such a notion you
know what I
mean all
right shall we uh call it a
day I'll get you a room get you do you
do you have a phone
not
yet I'll get you
one one way or another I'm going to get
you you you you one day maybe next week
I'm going to meet you I'll need
you I will Peter fron drive past your
house Blondie I guess you're
blond uh what har Debbie Harry she was
awesome
she is she still is yes she still
is I mean can you imagine there are very
few women at her age still doing like
still actually in the game let alone
[__] rocking
it